foreign
is dependent on the correct use of the
microphone which I was struggling with
therefore can I ask that when invited to
speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please reference a page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions clear
and concise please also be aware that
there are different levels in the
chamber so please be careful when moving
around the chamber entering or leaving
okay that's all that done
um okay uh item two apologies for
absence I haven't had any Tara have you
received any
I just traveled apologies from council
Mrs Thompson and councilman stunning is
attending as a substitute okay thank you
Tara any others
nope okay
um agenda item three are the minutes of
the last meeting and there's actually
two lots of minutes so I'm gonna do them
together so I'll need somebody to Second
them who went to both meetings so the
first minutes are up from the 10th of
November
2022 found on pages to 5 to 17 and
appendices 18 to 35
um and then the continuing continuation
of the meeting on the 28th of November
2022 which is on pages to 37-39 do I
have a seconder
thank you councilor Swain
okay agenda item four
um Declarations of interest to disclose
the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniary interests other
pecuniary interests
oh yes well there you go yeah I thought
I wouldn't agree I thought councilor
Swain agreed them but now councilor
fluke has raised the question okay
thank you Gemini I mean my understanding
was that that he'd actually seconded
your proposal and the members hadn't
been given the opportunity to to query
anything on accuracy so Jim and I really
just wanted to go
um to page 38
um
an in relation to not so much accuracy
chairman but I hope you'll take it but
at the top of the page where it says the
group manager customers provide an
update in respect for item five
um that still hasn't come forward
chairman even though we asked for the
update but chairman for accuracy I think
that as far as recommendations concerned
on on page 38
um I think that's actually is a
recommendation to a council we can't
actually approve those I don't think
okay Tara can we update that
that's why it says recommended rather
than resolve to recognize you that's why
it's a practically it was a resolution
of the committee same result but it's
recommended
so many as a recommendation Kevin if I
if I can come back there was if I
remember like a certain amount of
descent particularly when we got to the
second ones about what we were actually
doing and what we actually supported and
when we realized that we couldn't change
anything as part of the recommendation
the whole thing fell over so
um I mean if the clerk is satisfied that
that then still goes gives us the
opportunity to debate them on the same
grounds as this committee debated them
when we get to full Council then yes I'm
I am satisfied that but you know I think
officers should be mindful that the next
meeting of four council is likely to
extend past 10 o'clock from what I've
seen so far and I've said it before I've
said it to the chairman and I've also
said it in relation to this meeting that
we should all have a save the date the
other time for save the day because I
you know if we run over tonight when's
the business of this meeting going to be
conducted
um and members should be made aware of
the possibility and when that's likely
to happen
and I I think you've indulged me now on
all the minutes okay yeah before I go to
cancel Channel I will say that I've
already been in contact with Mr Dodson
and I've asked about which I haven't
seen yet
um should we go over time so it is in
hand and a meeting will convene within
the next five working days that if we
have to go into a secondary meeting it
will be sooner rather than later because
obviously that was my concern as well um
okay councilor channel uh thank you
madam chairman if we're talking about
the recommendation on page 38 I think we
are yep that was dealt with Madam
chairman
has been dealt with
okay thank you agreed at the council
yeah okay is everybody do I still have a
second for those yeah are we all agreed
yep okay uh thank you everybody okay
right moving on uh Declarations of
interest to disclose the existence and
nature of any disclosable pecuniary
interests other pequinary interests or
non-convery interests relating to items
of business on the agenda having a
regard to paragraph six to eight
inclusives of the code of conduct for
members do we have anybody in the
interest counselor Channel
uh thank you madam chairman a gender
item number 11 council tax discretionary
discount levels
um chairman um I've expressed an opinion
uh sort of a national level and
therefore bearing that in mind I'm not
going to participate in the discussion
or vote Madam chairman thank you okay
that's absolutely fine um do I have any
others
no
thank you okay moving on
um
a gentum item six which is public
participation do I have any members of
the public speaking
my channel we don't have any okay thank
you very much okay agenda item seven
notice of motion on pages 39 to 40 to
consider the following motions submitted
by councilor a.s Fluker Julie seconded
by councilor MW Helm and referred to
this committee by the canceled its
meeting on the 3rd of November 2022
motion that the council brings forward
the 2023-24 budget and a fully costed
23-27 corporate plan at the same time
and in advance of the 23 Municipal year
further details in this motion submitted
by councilor Fluker is attached
um so does anybody have
um I'll open the floor okay councilor
Fluker yeah thank you I think it's
normal isn't it for me to open and then
then uh and then speak last but German
you know I bought for this motion to
council basically on on the basis of
what's there I mean the council was
facing versus situation whereby out and
the bad project deficit of going from
280 to 780 pounds 80 000 pounds I mean
that is a huge amount of money and it
does equate to 15 000 pound a week since
then we've received additional
Government funding which has reduced
that figure but you know that really is
a windfall it's not something that we're
going to expect every year
um and I think that overall given the
financial position the council it's in
my mind that
it's imperative that the council agrees
the budget and a fully costed corporate
plan at the same time I mean today I was
in a meeting this afternoon and and I
sort of had a glimpse from an officer
about what was like to be in this
corporate plan and it is absolutely in
my mind imperative that you know what's
planned is actually put on the table now
and it's seen in relation to the budget
because I think it works well together
and I still think that it's very very
important that we have both on the table
when we start the new Municipal year now
I had hoped that this this
um motion was going to come forward at
the meeting in this committee uh on the
10th I think it was but that would have
been uh seven days after this uh seven
days after I proposed this at Council so
it would have just missed the agenda I
did ask if we could have dealt with as
an urgent item and that was refused so
that side
um I then asked if it could come to the
uh the the the adjourned meeting and it
couldn't obviously because it wasn't on
the agenda and it hadn't been taken but
Kevin we will be we will be the only
Council that I can find in the United
Kingdom that will not be bringing
forward a corporate plan alongside its
budget at the beginning of the new
Municipal year I think it would be
remiss of this Council not to do that I
think the reason that officers have
attended so far is the fact that we're
going to get a new Administration well
every four years we get a new
Administration nobody quite knows what
it's going to look like nobody foresaw
what was going to happen at the last
election and nobody knows what's going
to happen at this election my gut
feeling is is that there will be a lot
of new members chairman I doubt whether
anybody will be in overall control of
this Council and we're going to have
very very few experienced members and I
suspect in some ways Tim and we're going
to be the council is going to be quite
politically disjointed people will be
wanting to feel their way into the
council and the first thing they're
going to ask them to do is to look at
some very very difficult corporate
projects and sort out the court put plan
this is not going to happen quickly this
is really not going to happen quickly
and I would rather hope that the
officers agree to this motion so that we
can bring forward the corporate plan and
I'm sure that the experienced members
that all the the council members now
yeah would support it from what I've
heard and that then gives gives you a
clear run yeah at the start of the
municipal year to do it the other way
around chairman I fear that we could hot
tie the council for quite some time
so my you know my my motion was brought
in all good faith and disappointed
really that the chairman chose
not chose to apply the rules uh and not
deal with this at Council because I
think it would really really help the
director of strategy and resources to
get this plan approved before the end of
this Municipal year thank you chairman
yeah I mean I will say that I have
actually already requested a breakdown
of statutory and non-streetry
um
sort of payments that we have to make
and duties that we have
um so that that is in hand already um I
asked a little while ago and anybody
else want to see councilor Channel well
uh thank you madam chairman I mean I
think some of councilor fluka's motion
been answered through the process of the
finance working group which you yourself
actually do chair and if I think at this
I recollect came up about the corporate
plan and in fact the last meeting it's
quite unfortunate Mr Leslie that was on
the agenda
um I know it's a prime and complicated
but it is what you've just said Madam
chairman talking about
um
service review and sort of looking at
things and costings unfortunately I was
one of those that was unable to
participate fully as yourself and
counselor stamp was more fortunate than
us she managed to get back in we all had
internet problems
um but um and therefore that discussion
councilor Swain was I think cheering
because a new absence and I'm sure
Council Swain will correct me if I'm
wrong but I do recall we couldn't then
participate further in the discussion of
that item and I believe it's coming up
and also I believe there's some sessions
four members regarding the corporate
plan we've got the engagement period
Madam chairman yeah okay I make those
points yeah before I go to Mr Leslie
I'll ask the other questions then we can
take them all together because that'll
save some time okay but cancel the stamp
then cancel lagging thank you madam
chair
um mine's not
um such a question it's mainly an
observation uh in the fact that Council
Fleming and I've spent old old morning
at County this morning talking about
their finances it's all open and
transparent I've not broken any
confidentialities it's streamed live on
YouTube if anybody wants to watch it and
I I'm actually in agreement with
councilor fluka I was also somebody who
suggested and wanted the corporate plan
to come out before because what you do
normally when you plan a budget you have
your targets and you fit your figures
around to your targets you don't turn
around and put a budget together Madam
chair and then put a corporate plan
around it that's the way I work and as I
turn around and said I hope I'm not
breaching any confidentiality I was at
that meeting Council political was that
this morning this afternoon and I I sort
of put it as an example of as a puzzle
Madam chair you have to have all the
pieces to make a puzzle and at the
moment I feel as though we don't have
all the pieces and strategies to be able
to make a puzzle and what I will do in
in before the actual main agendas
meeting starts is that congratulate the
reports that have been done by the
section 151 officer it's very
comprehensive but as far as this motion
goes I'll second this motion because I I
also believe we should have a corporate
plan or some direction or some strategy
that we can follow and councilor fluke
has dead right by saying that we could
have many many inexperienced counselors
and that's no detriment to them and
hopefully some of the experienced
counselors and the ones who want to
stand again stand again to be able to
support them but at the moment I'm
afraid I don't I think the corporate
plan needs to come alongside the budget
and the finance because I don't think
we've got enough resilience without
using our reserves or environments or
whatever you want to call to actually
meet meet those targets if they're
agreed because we haven't seen the
corporate plan Madam chair thank you
thank you um Council again
I'll be much quicker because
everything's that I wanted to say sorry
thank you for once in a while I'll be
quiet thank you okay do you have any
other questions before I go to miss
Lizzy okay cancel the swing
yes thank you chairman
um yes first year I think this is quite
impractical particularly to the idea of
fully costed up to 26 7.
um because there were so many things
that have got to be changed in the
meantime and that's not just a question
of having some rather generalized ideas
about corporate plan
um one can easily float some of those
before um uh before the new
Administration comes in and I think
councilor fluke was somewhat sort of um
contradicted himself by saying we should
we should get on with this and and
preempt what the new councilors might
want to do
um so I think it has to and the
situation is we have got a reasonable
23-24 situation it's after that that the
problems need to be addressed and that
is where
um some fundamental issues need to be
discussed and I think that is for the
new Council to take on board so I think
this is um
um not appropriate and not workable and
a rather sliding on any possible new
members who may come in in May okay
thank you and I'll take offense at
sliding when I said it I said no about
the new members coming in so I wanted
noted there was no slight on members new
members coming in thank you okay
oh don't go first cancel the channel
have you got something I need to add I
forgot to say one thing regarding also
of course don't let's not forget the
members briefing regarding the budget
and Mr Leslie did give an indication of
going forward thank you absolutely
counselors
thank you madam chairman uh I agree with
councilor fluka I know
however
however however
that would be the idol situation
and we're not in the ideal situation
because at the moment we don't have a
formed corporate plan and it's a it's
it's a bit disappointed that we don't
have a form corporate plan at this
particular stage
um and we need to ensure that we have
that form corporate plan so that we can
ensure that we are spending our money in
the right way and using it in the right
way
and and I I can see the need to do that
however
we want to make sure that the corporate
plan that comes forward is one that's
going to be workable and is going to fit
the next Administration
uh yeah so so we're I think my view is
is we're in a country at the moment
because we're in this difficult
situation where we're having to set
budgets but we don't have a have a
defined corporate plan I know the
corporate plan is is being defined at
the moment uh and that then puts us in a
very difficult position in terms of you
know bringing that forward in a timely
manner and what we mustn't do is rush it
um so you know I'm sort of a bit in the
in between
okay
okay so swamfully by counselor oh we're
gonna have one councilor stamp and then
Council Durham and then
a couple of quick points um when I
referring back to what council stamp
says rather that
um Council of flu could seemed to imply
that people are coming into the council
wouldn't be able to coming in refresh
wouldn't be able to contribute in the
same way as the long-standing experience
councils
um but the other point is you mentioned
what Mr Leslie has done on um uh trying
to
um come up with a segregation of
um just uh statutory against uh
discretionary
um items of expenditure that seems to me
particularly an area where the incoming
councils would have something to say
yeah uh thank you councilor Swain uh
councilor stamp just for clarity we do
have a corporate plan because my
signature is on it and it finishes in
2023 so just for accuracy
okay thank you Council councilor Durham
well I was just going to say that very
thing you know if we haven't got a
corporate plan you know what the hell
have we been doing for the last two or
three years but I do agree
um with
the the corporate plan will probably
need to change significantly because
we're in a very different place
and I've got a very straightforward
question
Is it feasible to come up with a
meaningful corporate Plan before the
election or is it not
yes or no answer okay Mr Leslie over to
you
okay absolutely we need a corporate plan
that's appropriately resourced and the
medium-term financial strategy the
budget and the corporate plan of course
need to need to align I think the
proposals that we're looking at going
forward that is part of the development
of the corporate plan is that the budget
forms a key part of that and is reviewed
in line so the budget Moves In
accordance with the corporate plan we
know the financial challenges that's
ahead of us and it's important as part
of that budget work we get all the
options on the table that we talked to
members about in terms of equal member
briefing how that will shape up in the
process for that and then those options
can be informed by the corporate plan
which will set the priorities and then
we can say actually here the options
here's our priorities and we can get the
two to align so I think that that's the
process it's not a case so that we're
set in something now that's set in stone
it's fluid it should change as required
and it should develop as part of that so
it should fit in the time frame of the
corporate plan so he's absolutely the
intention to align the budget and the
corporate plan I think that's that's
absolutely a sure in terms of that
can we do it before may I feel I've been
put on the spot with that one I think
it's absolutely going to be incredibly
challenging to do that and when you
think about public consultation and all
the steps within that I guess I can't
give you the definitive answer now but
it's challenging but I think the
reassurance is that the two the budget
and the corporate plan have to align and
need to align as we go forward
at my point of view
um reading this I mean I I think we
should start when we get these I don't
other members think when we get all
these
um reports in that we start putting the
corporate plan together and if it gets
put together before the election's fine
but I think if we get it so far through
that at least it's a stepping stone for
any new members
um so I I don't know what you'd like to
do I know you'll take the vote as it is
or if you'd like to cancel it at fluka
no I said that I can't sleep
um
so it seems to me so maybe the
opportunity to perform this course
because that could change significantly
and based on what the 151 obviously says
if the pain is going to change
significantly at the beginning of the
rest of the year then the budget has to
change
now that then really takes us into
incredibly dangerous territory if you
start texting people with the with the
budget
um so there's some of the points that
are always my members I was at the last
meeting Financial Group right I
appreciate that from the connectivity
but generally speaking I think there was
a certain amount of
um I won't say concern but there was a
certain amount of phenomenal questions
about this because this council is not
used to this happening
it was like Awards reviewed it I noticed
that last week we were early on this
week we all invited to a
picture you know it's clear from work
science budget it's been a huge amount
of work going on about how the last few
months so while we didn't have sessions
on the corporate a few months ago I
don't know but of course the backstop
touring proceeds is that if council is
this Council of this Administration was
to agree to uh to a corporate plan
foreign
six months later
and councilman Swain questioned my
narrative about a fully not sleeping
I plan to 23 27. per person I should
direct into some of the reports of one
Vibes that will be able to consider
later on this evening because they
actually speak to those years so I think
it's important that last 151 officer
it's not an ideal situation
but
Maybe
my final question is
why don't we have the new corporate
but somebody explained it why don't we
actually have a new corporate that up
and ready to go to council to be
approved I think that's the big question
if it's to do with the fact
that I'm sorry that I really do not run
into this opportunity
changed very very easily
um but yeah I'll talk about that that's
apart from the politically implications
why don't we have hospitals
ready
okay I think I'm going to Mr Dodson now
chair
yeah yeah as others have said we do
still have a corporate plan that that is
still
current it's 20 the update was 2021 to
2023 updated two years ago
and that has been used in the the budget
planning process and will be used as as
we we go forward
the the reason is the reason that was
given previously around you know I'm
totally convinced that if we if we went
through that that process now we'd be
doing it again
in the summer in any case because we
will have
um a new Council and a new
Administration so
the the reason is that the the current
plan is
um fit for purpose for for this this
process we can go through we will be
updating the the um
Performance Management process
um and looking and setting the targets
Link Link in the the current corporate
plan and those budgets making sure that
the resources are matched together we
will then finalize we'll do all of the
work on the consultation and the
discussion around the the corporate plan
it'll effectively be
um ready to go
as we as we go through the election but
then we will need to go through that
process of validating it and making sure
when the major budget challenges which
are shown in the the medium-term
financial strategy from 24 25 onwards
that we have that to to deal with those
and go through that process starting as
as Mr Leslie said earlier than we ever
ever have before in that budget planning
process
um in the new Municipal year
councilor stamp and then we're going to
vote on the motion thank you thank you I
think it's only right that we can
respond to the directors
um words Madam chair in the fact of um
I'm a little bit relieved that he says
at the Mr Dodson said that they will be
ready to go so can I ask a question of
Mr Leslie does that mean that the
figures that we're going to agree
tonight and from the 4th to 20 23 to 27
you're taking into account because
you've been in the meetings with the
directors thinking about the corporate
plan
so I'm actually asking if it goes from A
to B to C to D not from a to d so have
you actually had meetings with with the
officer the director with the vision of
what you're you're right in the
corporate plan it then gets approved at
Council you're right and the members
aren't writing it
that's what I'm saying so have we now
actually agreed the figures or have you
agreed the figures and is it
Incorporated tonight
no if we talk about the the corporate
plan that yet to be written then then no
that they don't include
okay
life on support piece about you
so the budget obviously approved uh in
February time on 22nd of February for
Council so that's obviously in advance
of the administration of course an
Administration may wish to make changes
to the budget and that's of course
within their gift
okay right so we have a motion on the
table
and
um oh gosh I've got it here now and um
the Preamble is uh oh it's from Council
fluka seconded by councilor Helm and
councilor dueck and I just wanted to oh
I can't do it yeah I'll say and so we
could go to make a recorded vote
Tara
thank you
okay right um so we'll go to the vote
now
um and we'll clear your name out then
you can vote all those in favor of the
motion by councilor fluka if you could
please show the one by one they'll call
you out yeah sorry get recorded yep
to greet the council brings forward the
23-24 budget at a fully costing 23 27
corporate players at the same time and
we've got the 23 Municipal years so
starting with Council of class in
Japanese form
council Mrs China against
Council Durham
four actually
swimming against
or
Council wagon four please Tara
against
that's the sigil against
[Music]
four
cancer sweating against
uh I'll abstain as chairman
I've got my full private kids
um I'm going to vote
um for purely because I want to start
the process I don't think we can finish
it but I want to start the process
okay right moving on to the
um next agenda item which the gender
item eight
um to consider the following reports of
the director right of resources
let's over to Mr Leslie
the committee receives regular updates
on the budget uh and there has been uh
the member Finance working groups as
well met several times uh this year
additionally all member budget briefings
were held on the 29th of November and
the 17th of January the reports reflect
the previous information presented and
provide the latest updates
despite the significant inflationary
challenges the current year position is
forecast to be 138 000 pound overspend
or just over one percent of the total
net budget however the approved budget
contains drawdowns from the general fund
which is expected to reduce the balance
to 4.7 Million by the end of this
financial year
the next year the use of general fund
balance is budgeted to be used again and
that's 421
000 pounds as well as the inflationary
pressures continue to impact and that is
set out in the report this is going to
impact of the inflationary pressures
uh the changes from this year to next
are summarized on table one on page 76
the general fund balance is forecast to
be 4.3 Million by the end of next year a
council tax increase of three percent is
also included within the budget
future years are budgeted showing the
implications of taking no action with
those years being a very Financial
financially challenging and I draw this
to members attention at the end of my
Assurance statement on page 135
the capital program is on page 101 with
no borrowing required although Capital
reserves are decreasing to fund the
program
okay members
um do any questions
we do
this is always
okay yep so
um the so go back to 41 I've got from
all the way through this
so um we will start at God I'm on 51
let's go down to 41.
foreign
I don't know how you want to split these
up really do you want to talk about the
individual items that that are on um
page 52 Fords the individual budgets
we do it that way around
so the appendices for me they're all the
individual items so do you want to do
the individual budget items
um I don't know maybe typically where it
says
um
if any suspension permission
to the Future Council or wheat or any
large amounts of funding
um I don't think it's the case
invest in huge amounts
I'm surprised that this report is silent
uh development and
and the other things that the treasury
in the Treasure University
Bank
what's happened
yes I get uh this covered uh in a bit
more detail in a gender item nine the
treasury management strategy
which sets out the counterparty limits
and provides a bit more detail around
that I believe it's a a minus rating we
also have our treasury advisors who send
through our counterparty lists as well
and advise on latest updates around that
you can
check that statement is correct but we
all know that there are lots of
commercial projects so
I appreciate that this is a snapshot and
his face
a response to knowledge in schools
excessive because professionally
qualified and experienced staff in the
senior positions with the responsibility
of making capital expenditure following
the most important for investment
decisions so could one of our previously
based on the fact that we know about
officers and how to train
um I'll make vessels
funds Council
where we are or are we when I'm turning
on the outside Consultants
Miss Lizzy yep so we use our internal
staff to do that they have training
through Arlington and that's why we have
those external advisors and of course
members have been invited to a briefing
with those Consultants as well to to
understand a bit more detail about that
so we do that internally I think in
again in item nine that provides more
details of where we invest in the
counterparty limits as well surrounding
that
what do we want to go on to now do you
want to discuss each individual
um project or do you want to go into the
next part of the report 8B
is there anything else on the 8A that
you'd like to discuss I mean we we've
got the capital
um first of all we've got the service
Capital bids and then we've got the
capital project sheets
um
is there anybody ask any problems with
any of those uh councilor Fluker
when we look at
I
think sometimes we
have to invest ourselves to you know we
can't do both ourselves from the
contribution of the things
history but I find it very hard
then minus Council currently about 70
people with an emergency accommodation
1300 people on the uh
some of those multiples of families
um and I think save a challenge if it
figures
which is homeless people in the history
that we're trying to put together and I
find it very very hard to look at these
fields and see that this Administration
gets that backdrop is
Administration I mean there's hey
gaining for example I believe that that
is
quest for me to say that you know 226
000 pounds if we provided our own piece
of land we could build a four bedroom
house or two apartments for two homeless
people
um I know also that there's expenditure
in Riverside Park but I do think
chairman and it may well be something
that I bring forward it's my alternative
is your microphone on yeah I think so I
might not be closer to it but you know
it might be something that I might bring
forward in my own budget chairman to to
perhaps spread some of this chairman to
close the budget Gap and perhaps do the
right thing and then and invest in the
homeless and and the people that need
accommodation and and perhaps look
elsewhere for funding for The Galleon
and and chairman I thought to myself the
other day I was in the Promenade Park uh
and it was quite busy and I thought to
myself well you know you've got this
huge piece of equipment there I mean if
we if we had one of the house builders
come forward and built us a stockade
with a slide and a thing coming out the
side it would be you know it wouldn't
need all of this money spent on it
continuously
um maintaining it and it would be a
long-term investment so I find this I
find this very very hard to swallow at
this particular time okay before I go to
council again I'll go to Mr Holmes
thank you chairman just regarding the
items on uh appendix 2 for the play
equipment I think the situation we find
ourselves in that we need to main is
maintain them at the highest possible
standard and when they become at towards
end of life I think there's a there's a
choice and perhaps the choices we we
possibly remove them and we can't run
the sites unsafely
um I think you did read the detail with
the report you see that the maintenance
costs for them are increasing so it is a
little bit of a stark choice and we can
patch and patch and then reaches a point
where it becomes a such a cost that it's
actually
um you know prevents us you know looking
after them the way we wish to so I think
it's really as bleakers support them or
actually look at to remove them
um this this the um
I think Jim having looked at this so I
was going to make a comment but perhaps
I should make it privately to uh direct
to a service delivery I
do you want to agree these individually
as we go through them or how do you want
to do it because we need to get through
this agenda so I'll go to cancel login
and then councilor Swain and oh then
councilor shauncey thank you chair
um The Galleon I look at it from a
different perspective to cancel fluke I
mean it's a great asset and if it needs
replacing it needs replacing I mean it's
heaving down there it's well used
um I long for the days of the old speed
rate to come back down there in a
trampolines but that's because I'm old
and crumbly and grew up on there and
they were I'd say it was great and um
now my only question is as have we have
we looked at other options and other
types of equipment that might come in
slightly less than a quarter of a
million quid and
secondary for the ply equipment which I
agree with you is is some of it is very
old and outdated
um and the snail climbing frame please
keep that because that's a cracking
piece of Kit That's Unique
um
didn't there wasn't there a fund that we
had for refurbing that whole area
that was put aside I remember was it um
we were going to take the Maze and areas
out and that included a new paycom so is
this in addition to that fund because
that I believe was a hundred thousand
pounds as well
so just for clarity please yes that is
correct there's more equipment than
these replacing unfortunately you know
play equipment comes at a specification
than the standard and they recognize
suppliers for those things which
obviously does dictate the price we
obviously do look for Best Value all of
the time we will look to procure
um the other option around the
playground is to look to replace it
something on a different scale this is
putting it back at the scale it's a
landmark feature as you said and it's a
tourist attraction in its own right
um but they're absolutely right we could
do something more in scale and but I
think the point is something has to
happen and probably the existing
facility can't keep going on um the way
it is
okay I know you have to be really quick
so we need to get through the meeting
and then I think we'll take these
individually and we can either agree
them or not agree them
um councilor Swain then councilor
Shaughnessy then Council stamp uh yes
thank you
um Can the officers tell us how much
section 106 money is is available for
this sort of um uh play equipment room
so on
Mr Leslie
yeah I think we're potentially looking
at um sources of funding
um for for these areas there is
potentially some money we could use we
need to check on that and check the
agreements and what can be used
um I don't know if there's times you
have an exact figure
I don't have an exact figure tonight but
obviously one of the one of the places
mentioned earlier around the century
Garden top end of Promenade Park that
had a figure for 106 funding and the
council put a budget in this is a Top-Up
to get more of the equipment
um so the rest of them are existing uh
pieces of play equipment the council has
either funded itself or in the past
um had grant money to install
a short
um
okay Council Sean the sea then Council
stampling councilor China so Council
Shaughnessy
thank you madam chairman
um whilst of course we all have sympathy
for people in Dire Straits
um you know homing and the things that
councilor fluka has mentioned
but on the other side of the coin these
play areas are essential they are free
for these for families who uh you know
are struggling financially these are
free to take their children to you know
for exercise and to get them out thank
you okay thank you cancel the step
uh thank you um yesterday I was honored
to be able to go into one of the schools
as an inspirational woman and I asked
the kids I spoke to all the kids at
different yes you may joke but they they
invited me and it was brilliant
um and I actually asked the kiddies what
they wanted to do when they grew up Etc
and what they would like to see in
Burnham and their communities and they
said better Park equipment better play
equipment within the parks we like to
play out
um Mrs stamp and councilor stamp they've
said so I actually agree with this and
Mr Holmes and anything we can do to put
into our Parks because our kiddies do
like going and playing in the Parks and
it is free what council has shown as
this just said and you can normally sit
down with your picnic basket your bread
and marmalade or your banana or whatever
you're eating and you can enjoy it the
fresh air so I'm afraid I agree and I
support all of these bids Madam chair
thank you okay councilor Channel
uh thank you madam chairman again I
think this is something I can recall
discussions elsewhere Finance working
group and I think we looked at various
things
so we seem to be having a debate again
with various people on the finance
working group that where I thought this
had come from so I support that and
councilwagon's absolutely right
regarding the Galleon
um and I'm sure Council Shaughnessy as
well be be aware being modern as well if
the options you've heard from the
director of Service delivery what the
options are really and to me it's a
no-brainer if you remove that what are
you then going to do
uh councilor Fleming and then we'll go
to the vote we'll take them on block so
that all of them in one go and then if
it's not agreed we'll go individually
okay councilor Fleming uh thank you
chair just a question for Mr Holmes um
going back to councilor Swain's point
about section 106 monies so if I'm to
understand it correctly the Riverside
Park skatepark equipment 140
000. that's on top of
monies we've received from developer
contributions because my understanding
was that there were you know there are
Developer contributions from there and
then also the prom Park so the figures
are in addition to what
to the developer contributions is that
right
chairman I might put Mr Butcher on the
spot this evening because I think he's
sitting with some 106 information in
front of him um so could we ask Mr
butcher if he could comment on that
please
Mr butcher
good evening members good evening
plan that we've been working on
that's all requests for is um he's
urgent um
urgent changes that we need to make
which could compromise health and safety
of current equipment there is section
106 money on top of that but in most
instances the 18620 we've received is um
is more applicable for for youth uh for
skate park could be an extra that kind
of thing rather than rather than play
equipment but we do have a spin plan
which gives a section a capital plan
which is a breakdown for section 106 and
capital
um uh capital investment required Right
Here and Now
okay
um councilor fluka and then we'll go to
the vote
for us
foreign
I've got the microphone on for the
benefit of the people this afternoon but
I'm sorry some of those people can't
even uh afford to take the bus from
Burnham to southminster and that's the
sadness of this thank you chairman
thank you Council worker okay
um so if we can
yeah I think we don't need to record
development which is a show of hands
can't we yeah show of hands all those in
okay we'll do another recorded vote then
please Tara
are you under for each one individually
no do them all as a whole and if they
fail then we can go and do them
individually
was it councilor fluka Then followed by
an insecutive by councilor Lagann I
think
um
okay well okay we can do them in in
books then with the first plot which the
two replacement vehicles
um so um Tara if you could do a roll
call and either vote for or against
yes yeah so it's the first two together
then the next two and then the last two
so it's the first two one and two
okay
um
[Music]
stay when I call your name please talk
to me Council passenger four please Tara
or the replacement
um Vehicles yeah
replacement Vehicles yeah thank you I
cancel darling for
eign
[Music]
four
eight four Tara
's no extensions
okay
actually just just to sort of like to
mention that these are recommendations
to council yeah so okay yeah so the
recommendation the first one is
recommended to council the second one
board and Promenade Park which is three
and four so it's the Galleon and the uh
sensory play equipment so again four are
against and Tara will do roll call
2010 uh members four against starting
with cancer Passenger please four
he comes versus his channel for
Council four
against
very much full please Tara
C
four
thank you Tara
actually that's 10 for one against no
exceptions okay and the next one is
Riverside Park it's the skate park
equipment and surface and the play site
equipment
um so it's items five and six their
recommendation going forward to full
Council going to be a um independent
individual vote a recorded vote so um
Tara if you could do a roll call please
members it's for and against
so when you're ready Tara
thank you chairman uh also I transcribe
to six it's got to be Council Passenger
please for
if you don't see this channel
or
nothing for South means the election
coming up against
someone
yeah four please Tara for the people to
burn
four
cancer
straight four
council is Right four thank you Tara
okay right now we'll go on to agenda 8B
which the medium term Financial strategy
oh do you want to go to the reserves
a so we can only increase
ah okay yeah
appendix three okay members I think
we'll do this on block um agenda
appendix 3 are we four or against the
book show hands agreed all in favor okay
thank you very much and then we've got
the the part four which is the minimum
Revenue provision statement appendix 4
be approved
um we'll agreed
thank you members okay right now we'll
move on to part eight
okay
um the oh God he's doing it all
separately okay it's the eight a capital
uh strategy members um four against
please for thank you very much okay
right now we'll get on to
um 8B which starts on page 75 which is
medium term Financial strategy 23 24 to
25 26 okay members
Mr Leslie
yeah you covered it already Okay uh
members do we accept this strategy
Council Fluker
no he's already done it earlier he did
it in uh
sorry just a couple of questions really
I'll be brief page 76
um the get fund from the general fund I
I always find I always find local
Authority accounts quite difficult to
follow you know I'm one of these people
that just goes to the bottom line on the
piano but it is it is a bit complicated
and you know I these 22 23 figures the
get funding from the general fund which
is the figure I normally go to
um you know we've got four five three in
there for 2023 which has now gone to
938. I thought that we'd actually
managed to reduce that down to with the
new government funding it actually come
down
um and if I can just go
Um onto the growth items on page 77
um it says here during the budget review
several budget growth items were
identified as being required to meet
service demand and Carry Out Council
policy these have been scrutinized by
the finance working group and reduced to
the following amounts
um whatever the whatever the original
amount was
um from that statement it appears that
the finance working group made a
decision
and they've taken a figure and then
reduced it so I'm a little bit concerned
because I don't believe they've been
agreed by Council and working groups
shouldn't be making those decisions
um and and again chairman I'm when we
talk to the general fund on page seven
78 7.1
um when we look at the the reductions in
the general fund
um it the way I read the cancer I've
probably read them wrong those figures
don't actually if you try and
extrapolate the other figures they don't
seem they must balance because they know
the 151 officer wouldn't bring anything
forward unless it bounced but they they
don't seem to reflect the other figures
but of course you know councilor Swain
was saying about you know 25 26 27 but
there you see it
um you know the closing general fund
balance in 24 25 is 1.4 million
um you know pray God it never happens
but an extraordinary circumstance like
the pandemic would put us into a huge
difficulty
um we've spoken tonight about all sorts
of corporate projects things do come out
and of course when we get to 25 26
um it's all gone in fact it's all gone
minus two million pounds so you know one
wonders chairman bearing in mind that
the the potential dissolution of this
Council if Essence County Council get
their way will take place around about
that time is this the strategy a council
um
not on the finance working group I am
indeed and I sit there intensely
listening to this and and chairman I I
am concerned sometimes and and you will
see throughout this report there I've
never seen so many references to working
groups you know all this time working
groups are really there to to steer
officers they're not there to make
decisions and I'm sorry but you've got
it in black and white there contrary to
the constitution of this Council that a
working group has made a decision
whatever that was to pair that down the
pairing down of that should be reported
in in this budget process because to do
otherwise would be contrary to the
Constitution and all members should be
involved in that decision-making process
the likelihood is they'll follow the 151
officer but chairman I'm sure this is
the only time it's happened but we
should be aware of it thank you
councilor stamp chairman I think maybe
people are sick of me sometimes when I
say about working groups making
decisions I've banged on about it
because I thought it happened when we
were new members on a regular basis and
I actually thought we had stopped so I'm
I'm in uh agree with Council fluke we
shouldn't do it but can I make a
suggestion if you don't mind Madame
chair when it goes to council when when
you go through these documents there are
copious amounts of information and when
we had the presentation today at County
they actually took it in stages now the
next at full Council you're going to
have 31 members some of us have actually
sat on this now but if you don't explain
it properly all you're actually doing
Madam chair asking this Council today is
nod them through so I think if it's all
right with Mr Leslie you're excellent at
presenting and slides can can some of
this actually go on the big screen and
explain it Fuller to people I mean I'm
looking because I've done a lot of
training recently and Essex and you're
excellent at tutoring me but I
understand it better than I've ever done
but there's lots of members you're going
to be asked to make a decision who won't
understand this and I think it's really
important about getting our financials
and our figures figures right you don't
have to it's a suggestion yeah and in
fact this was brought up for me with the
Sip for accounting at a recent LGA event
yeah so I've already we're working
things behind the scene and you are
right about working groups not making
decisions I think that's probably a slip
of the pen but Mr Leslie wants to come
back on that one Mr Leslie
yeah thank you um I think of page 76 uh
the reference to
um obviously if you look at the bottom
line in the table one uh sorry we had
original budget gap of 453 000 pounds
um then that grew to through
supplementary estimates
um further side of it and it's the 23 24
year where that additional Government
funding comes in to reduce the um the
Gap we can do that that falls down but
where there was additional Government
funding that was in uh next year 23 24
through the funding guarantee Grant
around that with regards to the
statement about a working group reducing
that I I'd assume that
um perhaps the wording wasn't helpful in
terms of that but that's not happened as
a result of the working group there's
not a reduction because of a decision or
otherwise by the working group so
apologies if there is confusion around
that as quite rightly said uh very aware
that it's not a decision-making body so
um just for clarity wanted to make that
point okay all member briefings as well
were held and I think you know there is
time pressures in the meetings which is
why I make quite a lot of time outside
of these meetings to to go through a
detailed presentation allow q and A's
respond to q and A's allow members to
come back outside of that so given the
time pressures and the actual extent of
consultation that's gone that's how I've
done that I appreciate that actually a
link to the report I think is what what
props is saying actually that's great
but let's try and Link it to the report
that may be helpful so absolutely take
that on board but I hope members do
appreciate that sort of effort and time
I've given to them outside of the
meetings
and just a point of clarity before I
give way to counselor
um
perhaps German based on what the 151
officer said would he like to now
rephrase 5.1 for clarity because his
understanding went on the working group
is slightly different to mine but I
think it's important for him to clarify
the words I mean perhaps uh yeah I think
it would be
oh yeah we're happy to uh amend that
when it goes to council well Germany
would be nice a big pun chairman it'd be
nice if one five one one five one
officer just said that
um it hadn't been phased properly and
perhaps they had been mistake made
um so I think he could probably do that
now
he did he did yeah he did Apologize no
no no I said that Jim but what I'm
saying what I'm actually asking for is
for what the wording should be I mean
the 151 officers just said that it's not
right so it can only be a word is
missing or something but I have a
different record collection of what went
on at the finance working group because
we were given a series of options and we
auctioneered them but perhaps German I
know you're Keen to get us all home uh
early so I'll take up the the 151
officers office offer but yeah perhaps
you might like to do it in the morning
yeah on a Tuesday yeah I think it's a
really good idea I think we can um
address this tomorrow and get the
wording changed as he said it wasn't
meant to say um that it was a decision
of the the working group moral
recommendation but um we can do another
time because that's just playing with
words and I think we haven't got time to
um do that tonight so okay cancel the
sway and then we'll move on to the oh
and cancel the channel then we'll move
on to the individual items
just a kind of thing um I thought that
these items in table two had in fact
gone through the last SNL
[Music]
which number are you looking at cancer
the table two that we
um which
um a gender item number I never skated
over at the time and almost nodded
through but
um I thought that was an SNR meeting
paid seven are you on page 77 5.1
um BS
drugs
I think they went to the um Finance
working group a number of those and a
number of those have actually been
already approved by Council for example
members training
um what was actually already agreed
um we call them all going to SNR I think
we might have seen them before through
the working group or other communities
within the chamber so it wouldn't have
been through the working group
possibly the members trading for example
was discussed um there as well a head of
Environmental Services role was
obviously discussed at the chamber so I
think some of them and that's just
trying to combine all those those
growths um but there are a couple
um that were through the working group I
think the easy tree and customer service
resource
thank you madam chairman I hope I'm on
that my I'm getting terrible trouble
here sticking I can't get to the right
Pages we're on the medium-term financial
strategy an appendix one I'd just like
to say
um I can't remember the page but 5.1 to
whatever it is actually explains about
the budget and the corporate plan and
everything that uh Mr Leslie actually
highlighted members earlier Council
stamp referred to the plan we already
have an existence with a photo on
because that was done under the review
and so I'd just like to make it the
point that what Mr Leslie said is
covered within this medium-term
financial strategy and how he explained
how it can change a medium-term
financial stretch is always under review
and he was quite correct in the
processes he highlighted to members
earlier okay I've got cancer stamp and
then cancel the leg and then cancel the
fluka I wanted to say congratulations
well done to the section 151 officer I
think what is done on 7.3 and I think
members do need to really realize that
he's actually said if it must be
emphasized that the current medium-term
Financial strategy projections are
unsustainable the figures in table four
are based on a do nothing and I think
he's absolutely spot on saying to
members and especially at full Council
if we're doing it do nothing we're in
trouble and I think sometimes I know
that it feels as though we're giving you
a hard time we're not we're actually
very grateful for all the hard work
you've put in and I am I've been looking
back at previous meetings and the
information and the detail you're
putting in and what we're getting from
you now is really good and I'm on a
network with other people in other areas
of different councils as I'm sure other
members are and you are doing
exceptionally well so I'd like to just
say Well done and thank you and you can
take your crash helmet off a little
while
I'll actually add to that and say that
when I went to an LGA event last week I
did actually say that the reports were
excellent and I I had no concerns with
the section one five officer in the
presidency reports we might not like
them but there's no problem with the
reports themselves
um cancer Lagan
mine's just a comment really it's it
came out of conversation about we don't
want to spend time playing with words
and I think whilst that's true I think
it's absolutely critical that if it
takes us longer to scrutinize and review
and understand the information in front
of us that that needs to happen I don't
think we should try and shortcut or try
and this is not a good pop at you the
chair is as you know I'm concerned about
the length of the agendas of most
Council meetings but I made no apology
for asking questions that scrutinize and
ask for more detail
um because that's really what we're here
to do and we have got that detail
tonight
um thank you councilor Fluker thank you
chairman um
I mean I'm sure that when when five off
one five one officer reports to council
he'll now add some more words that
saying that the budget was subject to
vigorous scrutiny by the strategy and
resources committee because after all
that's what we're here for this isn't
our money
um chairman I I really just wanted to go
and I hope I'm not in the right place on
to page 107.
um the budget deficit if you look at the
budget the projected budget deficit for
um 23.24 a lot of that
deficit is as a result of
supplementary estimates and and budget
growth so you know whatever it is that's
where it points to
um and I'm not for and I appreciate that
these these posts have been been agreed
by Council but I think when we start to
spend these amounts of money
um on particularly new posts
um I think it would be very very useful
um if officers could come back and and
just tell us what the outcomes
um to ensure the members that having
agreed to these these amounts of money
that we're we're getting good value
um I think that would be useful and the
other thing is Jim and I I heard you
mentioned sit for and I read and I don't
know if it was mentioned at your meeting
but um I was reading some stuff from sip
for online and they have very very
strong views about the use of reserves
uh and I haven't seen this mentioned in
any of these reports
um there is this overarching comment
that they have to be used for
emergencies
um but then again the emergencies that
that came out of the pandemic a lot of
those were met met by the funding from
government but it does concern me that
the Sip for guidance
um is that you should only use uh
reserves in in absolutely extraordinary
circumstances they should be used for
emergency items and not for popping up
the budget I don't know chairman if you
picked that up from your meeting uh well
thank you
um councilman I have already raised that
and we are working on it with the
section 151 officer but Mr Leslie wants
to come in now
yes I think that's absolutely um vital
to point that out and um councilor
stamps already referred to uh one
paragraph within the report and in my
introduction I also referred to my
Assurance statement on page 135 to the
end of that that really states that it
isn't sustainable too constantly use
reverse and that this my statement
should serve as an early warning of the
financial challenges ahead in 24 25 and
I think the report obviously does show
that so I think it needs to be said loud
and clear so say thank you
um for for the highlighting of that I
mean we have had the cove at covid
that's impacted on their Leisure income
that income impacted and waste in our
Collections and then of course we've had
the uh inflation side of it where we've
seen and that's documented here the huge
impact that that's had in terms of our
waste contracts and our staff bills and
then actually further to our Leisure
Center income as well so we've had had
massive shocks around that but we need
to get back on a sustainable footing
weekly year
yeah um and what I would say is when you
look at the budget growth I mean for me
I think the one the one post that we
must have is the customer service
resource because for me if we don't have
a customer service or our customers what
are we here for so that for me is the
one that I'm really really happy to
support
um and um that is on page 107.
um right members um are we okay to agree
this going forward to council agreed
excellent well done okay right moving on
to a gender item 8C which is the 2223
revised in 23 24 original budget
estimates I mean these these might
um obviously be open to interpretation
with SIP for and with the
um the corporate plan but members um any
questions
you know going back to what councilor
stamp said about trying to get the
information in front of members and
making sure they they um they read it I
mean this council did agree some time
ago that the all of the reports to
council would be headed with an
executive summary uh and I think in some
ways uh whilst that might be difficult
for some of these reports I think it
really would be useful uh and I've I've
had complaints of members that when they
when they look to the implications you
often see under finances it refers you
back to the report well that's very
difficult then if you're looking for you
know if you're looking for a summary and
you're not a speed
um reader
um one of the recommendations here I
understand that these recommendations
only apply to 2324 but because of the
seriousness of the situation in 24 25
and based on what the 151 officer just
said
um Gemini I think it you know I think it
would be meaningful that whilst we've
said under recommendation
Roman 1 D maintain the current policy of
a minimum general fund balance of 2.6
million well we know from the 151
officers statements that that's not
going to be possible within two years
time I think chairman that one an
additional recommendation that might be
useful to have there
um is is to highlight even though this
is the 2324 budget estimates that going
forward we will not be able to maintain
that figure because it to me it gives
the impression that going forward
particularly to 2020 24 25 and we are
going to have that policy we know that
that policy is not sustainable and I
think if we know that policy is not
sustainable in advance of the new
Municipal year then it's very very
dangerous to leave it in there without a
caveat saying that we might not be able
to achieve that in 2025 24 25 and
definitely
seven
I actually uh strained enough agree with
you on that one Mr Leslie can we amend
that somehow
um I think it's importantly we set a
minimum general fund uh balance and I
recommend a minimum balance it is set of
2.6 million I think if we go that is a
trigger that is a warning sign we should
not drip drop below that level and if we
do we need to put in place a plan to
recover that so I would not want to
remove was essentially a rewarding
system I think the the 8B the
medium-term financial strategy does
cover that issue and does highlight the
fact we will be dropping below that
level but the fact that we're going to
drop below is not a reason to remove
that Target it's a very important Target
and we really need to try and stay above
that so if I come back I agree with you
100 and I think it really is an
important Target but 25 26 will be down
to 1.3 million again I think you report
a slightly different figure so again
maybe I'm reading it wrong but I I
really do think even though in these
reports and when I say there words
buried what I mean by that is some
members won't be able to dig that deep
to find these very very appropriate
comments that you make but I think it
you know I'd like to think that perhaps
this this committee would agree to
um a a an addition I'm not talking about
getting rid of the 2.6 but an addition
saying that we may not be able to
maintain this policy
um going forward
coming from I don't think we can alter
that I mean I think that will just come
in with the corporate plan and the
budget but cancel the channel then
cancel the stamp
um Adam Sherman I think being on a
course recently like counselor stamps
and some other ones as well it's very
important we do listen to our 151
officer he will have done his due
diligence to come up with that statement
and I'm not going to sit here it's
asking us to make a change on that uh
statement or policy there's 151 officers
promoting to this Council I think what
we also need to remember and I'm not in
any way trying to minimize the situation
of this Council and I would hasten to
add every other authority in the country
actually is having a difficulties in
terms of budgets and what they may have
to do or not we have to remember there's
an awful lot of assumptions placed going
forward we also recognize that we've got
some do nothing scenarios and of course
this Council will be doing things Madam
chairman they've been highlighted early
in throughout the process of the finance
working group and in other areas so I'm
not prepared to sway from anything the
151 officer regarding the statement he's
made and to say um that we should say
that we won't hold that position of the
2.6 Madam chairman I'm sorry I cannot
support
I'll just don't count
chairman I was not questioning the
statement the insurance statement of the
151 officer I'm not doing that what I'm
trying to do is to totally I appreciate
under assurance and I haven't got it in
front of me but I'm pretty sure that
under Assurance the the 151 officer
makes it quite clear that moving forward
it's going to be very very difficult to
maintain the position that we're in and
I was I was just really asking the
question could that recommendation be
strengthened up a bit just to say that
we won't be able to keep you know in in
line with the 151 officers Assurance
statement we won't be able to keep this
2.6 million pound promise because we
can't I mean if if everybody's happy
with that I'm not
okay kill system I think we can reassure
counselor flu because that's not going
to be the case because after that
meeting because Mr Leslie very kindly
had a one-to-one with me when I asked
this very same questions about is that
reviewed annually and he assured me and
told me what uh what processes he has to
follow and it's not a guaranteed amount
every year so I think next year it may
be something different so whilst I
understand and I think it's it's
important what council fluke has said
and trying to make everybody aware of
the council's financial difficulties I
actually also agree with them councilors
who did the training course on Saturday
and we've got the second day on second
day on Saturday again
um that I'm reassured that Mr Leslie is
doing and following the sit for
regulations and the guidelines and I am
not concerned at the moment about his
work I am about the finances so I'm
happy to support this as it is and based
on that I'll withdraw my proposal thank
you okay Council Swain then we'll put
this to the vote Yes I mean I just like
this phase medium-term Financial
strategy it's not a strategy at all and
as Mr Leslie has pointed out in the text
it is simply a projection on a
do-nothing basis with a lot of unknowns
okay thank you um okay members do
as before I agreed okay thank you very
much okay moving on to agenda item nine
which is the treasury management
strategy on pages 141 to 188 so I'm just
that last item the revised and the
original budget estimates so yes yes
first one thank you very much okay uh
exactly as it's printed um okay agenda
item nine Mr Leslie yeah thank you uh a
couple of some of it to an extent um but
the strategy has been developed in
consultation with our external advisors
uh it's similar to previous years and
sets out how the council will manage its
Investments uh table three on page 148
sets out the investment limits for
counterparties within that and also on
page 156
this also sets out the types of
investment held by the council at the
31st of December
the list of Treasury management
practices that are set out in sifa's
treasury management code
that the council follows
they set out in appendix 2 and shows how
the council complies with those
requirements uh the report shows that
the council has no underlying borrowing
requirement as well
thank you chairman I I'm I mean I just
wanted Ben based on the question before
about I just wondered how agile we are
when we come to investing generally
because
um you know completely out of but when
those ghastly people
um
um transomics and cartang or whatever
his name was
um during that conservative debacle
um the interest rate shot through the
roof and and out the blue the NatWest
were offering 5.6 on a minimum
investment of a thousand pounds up to a
hundred thousand over two years I mean
do do we respond to that sort of sudden
swing an offer and and did we manage to
capitalize on the rise of the massive
Rising interest rates and bonds during
that period I mean during that period
Bonds were being sold on 80 government
bonds on 18 yield
um on each year for the first three
years
okay so the council follows three
principles with its Investments um
security is is its first
um priority second it's liquidity and
third its yield returns around that so
what the council place is is short-term
Investments up to um 12 months generally
which means that um where the markets
change it can within that short period
of time
um invest in in other areas so if the
interest rates go up generally we'll be
able to take advantage of that in in a
relatively short period of time
um similarly if they go down obviously
we'll be exposed to that in the uh
period of time but that does follow the
sort of three principles around that we
do have some longer term investments
um as well that have you already quite
good returns in the property fund and
also the Diversified income fund um
total five million in those two
literally Council agreed to so some time
ago and have before well as we've seen
the Investments or interest rates
increase we have been able to take
advantage of those increased rates
and
reflected in previous papers in the
medium term Financial strategy you can
see actually the significant financial
impact that's had around that projection
so we are taking advantage of those but
also investing based on those principles
and in accordance with our tragedy
management strategy and advice for my
treasury advisors
okay remember something else
so
um if we do we agree to
um
accept this report
agreed great German very detailed well
yes I agree with that yeah it was very
detailed okay
um agenda item 10 which is the council
taxes thought scheme uh 23-24 which is
Pages 189 to 216
which is Mrs Green I believe Madam
chairman may I just remind you I did
make a statement at the beginning I will
not participate in the discussion
although I think that's absolutely fine
if that can be noted please Tara
thank you
um this report um is an annual report
that comes to you to agree the local
council tax support scheme which is a
scheme that assists um customers with
council tax reductions based upon their
low income
a scheme that's before you tonight is an
essentially unchanged scheme the main
difference is that the government have
given us some additional discretionary
Grant which we're intending to discharge
through an additional 25 pounds payment
which will be awarded as part of the
discount at the start of the financial
year
the report before you confirms that the
only changes which are summarized in the
recommendations
are a cost of living increase which is
in line with the other DWP benefits
um in addition to that
um any legislative changes that are
being introduced in the housing benefit
scheme just to make this consistent with
the other comparable schemes
and there's a few minor technical
amendments to ensure that during the
year if there are any additional schemes
that are introduced to provide support
to customers that are on benefits but
anything that is awarded as an
additional local payment we can
disregard from our scheme so that
essentially the customers aren't getting
it paid in one hand and taken out of the
other
and as I mentioned at the outset
provision toward the extra 25 pounds
discount and to people who are on
receipt of benefit as of the first of
April
thank you members okay members
um any got any comments while we're here
uh councilor Fluker yeah chairman I mean
we're only speaking I don't have a
problem with this I've not had a problem
with it in the past but there was just a
couple of points in there that I I
wondered if Miss Queen could perhaps
just clarified uh 3.3.1
um it says the lcts for 22 23 to date
has been largely contained within the
collection fund
so did you get that side Thunder
collection fun
um and
um I just wondered if you could just
maybe give a little bit even for more
information around there because we've
got a collection fan so what would
normally be that collection fan be used
for and how we can afford to take that
out and my other com comment is is how
many people actually
um get this Grant and and how much does
it cost
um and again it works his impact on
resources Financial it just says the
cost proposed scheme is largely within
budget
um but it doesn't speak to the budget
within the report so again under the
implications that doesn't really give a
true reflection of what's going on or
inform the members
things
with regards to the number of people
that are on receipt that is in um Parts
section six the implications
so so there's yeah three uh
3332 versus 300 000 3500 in the previous
year
um in terms of the scheme being cost
neutral the aim is that this scheme
doesn't attract an overall increased
cost year on year so what we are seeing
is a although the total amount of
potential benefit goes up we are paying
out less to less numbers of people so
overall there isn't an overall increase
we also take into account any
implications in collection losses so
when we look at that we're just looking
to make sure that the scheme as it is
doesn't cost us more year on year and at
the moment that is the case if we for
example saw a significant increase in
the numbers of people claiming benefit
then that would be an additional cost
those the sort of triggers where we
might then need to look at the scheme in
terms of keeping it cross-neutral
thank you uh councilor stamp then cancel
the channel thank you very much Council
again and do um do the officers foresee
an increase because obviously looking at
the um Financial States at the moment of
the whole of the UK and the world
globally
um I think you're going to have more
people that are going to be looking for
for help so have you actually looked
into that at what late what stage the
break even would be because I would hate
that we can offer a much needed service
from this Council when the when it is
needed if that makes sense so I'd rather
if if and when you come to this Council
and Council polka closure is because you
won't like this but if if you come to us
and say we need more money would you
feel you could come to us so we could
support our residents in need if that
makes sense thank you
um Madam chairman the the scheme
um if we are proposing to make any
changes to the scheme we would have to
undertake a full consultation process
with residents and obviously with
members
um and at that point there would be a
list of choices so it could be that
members wish to
um retain the current scheme or maybe
they wish to reduce the current scheme
and that would be a choice for members
at this point once the scheme is
approved this would be the scheme that
would be approved for the year so it
wouldn't be changed and but what would
come before you next year is possibly
some revisions to the scheme with some
options if we did see a significant
increase in expenditure
okay yeah thank you thank you um so
we're not flexible we can't be flexible
then this year so if there is a sudden
Spike which we most probably I think
there will be there's nothing where we
could be able to do for our residents
that much in need I just think find it's
really difficult would there be other
options for our residents that could get
some financial help from if they needed
it
Madam chairman this scheme isn't hasn't
got um an overall cap to it so it's
based upon
um a set of criteria and if the resident
is entitled to the benefit based upon
that criteria They will receive it in
this year
um what we might see is if we see the
expenditure increasing during the course
of the year then the scheme that comes
forward to you next year may have to be
reviewed to take account of the fact
that we are experiencing higher
expenditure but it isn't something we
would do in year and anybody that is
entitled under this scheme would receive
that income
thank you um councilor Chandler yes
apologies Madam chairman I it's the next
item I can't speak on so I do beg your
pardon no problem I jumped ahead of
myself with this wretched um system
tonight I'm I'm it's all sticking all
over the place can I just then go to
page 193 because I can't find the other
Quest page now I had a question on and
it was to do actually with persons um
with higher uh disabilities I think the
wording may have been but on page 193
and it is to do description of proposal
policy service and it's the bottom line
actually there are no proposals to
change the current scheme other than to
mirror National changes so to me there's
changes coming to the scheme because it
says there's no proposals to change the
current scheme other than to mirror
National changes so we're changing
something
the 25 pound addition if if we are
referring to 25 pounds additional
payment that is a national scheme but
what we need to do is we need to have a
policy as to how we administer that
scheme which is why that is in that
report because one of the appendices is
the detail of the scheme under which
that payment is made but the actual
scheme itself is based upon a national
scheme okay I am looking at one of the
appendices that's why I've got that line
from on page 193 so okay thank you I
think that's answered
okay and um counselor Lagan I think I've
got next thing councilor Fleming yeah
one's just a quick one I think um the
screen's actually answered it so that's
that's a set Sam the 25 pound it's
nationally
it is yeah it's 25 pounds for everybody
who's in receipt of cancer tax support
as of the first of April okay and the
other thing is probably more to the
directors is that can we when we're
doing reports we reference in speech a
lot of things we call them customers
customers have a choice a resonance in
this situation so just it's just an
annoyance of Distinction in language to
make sure because if I had a choice
would I pay it but I have to pay it and
I gladly pay it so it's just something
that's always scratched my age thank you
okay counselor funny
thank you chair
um page 191 another question for my
screen I was quite surprised to see that
impact on customers that
um there's been a decrease do you know
why that is given that we're in a cost
of living crisis
um Madam chairman we have actually been
seeing a year-on-year decrease for some
years now so um
I've at this point I probably couldn't
give you a clear answer
um
but it is something that is continuing
so it's not we haven't seen
um the sort of the ride Perhaps Perhaps
this year we might as as Council Stan
prefer to we might start to see an
increase but it but the last couple of
years we actually have seen a bit of a
decrease
okay Council China
thank you madam Jim because I've now
managed to get to the point where I
wanted to on this sticky um table at
page 195 which is is the appendices
um appendix one
and it says to advance equality of
opportunity between people who share a
protected characteristic and those who
do not and it says the higher rate
disability benefits will continue to be
disregarded thereby protecting those
with specific long-term conditions who
fall within this group
can the officer please just expand on
that rationale to me please thank you
Mrs Green
sorry page 195
in the box top box to involve equality
of opportunity and it's telling you how
does the proposal policy serves me oh
sorry am I just thinking of equality uh
the equality aim and it's the third
bullet point down higher rate disability
benefits will continue to be disregarded
thereby protecting those with specific
long-term conditions who fall within
this group
was just seeking qualification on that
something's going to be disregarded if
you 've got higher rate disability which
will then protect persons with the
longer term conditions who
are they registered disabled or not um
I'm assuming they are
uh it just seems we're telling the
difference between people that might
have disabilities
thank you members um within this scheme
there are a number of disregards for
people that are in a receipt of
different types of benefits and some are
disregarded in full and some are
disregarded partially this is just
identifying that those that are
receiving the higher rate which are
those with the more significant
disablement needs or long-term
disablement needs will have all of those
benefits risk disregarded under the
scheme but there are different levels of
disregards for different types of
benefits
together
but I'm just trying to work no way up
the equality at bitten you know like we
disregard for certain people persons of
a disability and some understanding it
wrong and then those with a lesser well
well not less the disability they've got
a disability but they're obviously
getting the higher rate
um there seems to be a difference
between the two and so obviously that
must be something that's okay within the
equality act but to me it makes um I
don't know you're either equal with
disabilities or you're not but that's
probably because I need to understand
more thank you
uh councilor Fleming thank you chair
another question for Mrs Green um the 25
pounds is that automatically applied
um is my first question and then the
hardship fund how do people know about
that do we sort of do they have to sort
of
do research and then or is it something
that we
um make you know sort of promote
or make you know make the information
available because I'm just concerned
that we're seeing falling numbers you
know that we're not
making our help widely known thank you
um with regards to the um the the
hardship payments that is something that
um customers can apply for but probably
most importantly that officers will scan
for as part of an application so for
example if we've got somebody that is
really struggling to pay their council
tax and he's in financial hardship then
we wouldn't buy an application at that
point
okay members any more questions or are
we oh sorry Council Durham yeah thank
you just just very quickly you know
these schemes like this are absolutely
vitally important because one thing that
can turn our budget and mtfs on its back
would be a dramatic change in collection
rates
so you know if there's a significant
decrease in collection rates our
projected income is just going to
disappear so that you know the schemes
like this are absolutely essential
yes uh I I I I agree entirely okay
members are we okay to uh agree this
agreed lovely thank you okay moving on
so we are now on to agenda item 11 which
is the council tax discretionary
discount levels on pages 217 to 232
which is Mrs Green again and chairman
this is the one where I'm not partaking
okay Tara if you could record that
please
thank you
okay right Mrs Green thank you chairman
um so this report is coming before you
because
um we are asking members to consider
whether they would like to amend some of
these discretionary discount levels
following some changes in legislation
but just to give you some background
um we currently uh
charge a what was called a long-term
disc a long-term premium for properties
that have been empty for over two years
so this change was introduced some years
ago and it was intended to bring
properties encourage properties to come
back into use
so the charge only kicks in after the
property has been empty for two years
and thereafter there is 100 premium
a couple of years ago the government
changed the legislation to enable us to
provide a further opportunity to
encourage owners to bring those
properties back into use by expanding
the charge that could be payable and on
that occasion members did agree that
they would start to charge the maximum
premium which is set out at 3.3 in the
report which is currently there's no
charge for the first two years after two
years as a hundred percent premium after
five years there's a 200 premium and
after 10 years of being empty there's a
300 premium so that's the scheme as it
currently stands
um the new legislation enables members
to consider rather than charging the
premium after two years to actually
charge the premium after one year
and again that's encouraging those
properties to come back into use from a
much earlier date
so that is the first option before
members this evening would you like to
consider charging that empty Home
Premium after 12 months rather than two
years
and the second option that's before user
relating to Second homes that are
nobody's sole or main residents so
property that might be used for weekends
or might be partially furnished but not
really in use
up until now we haven't been able to
charge any additional charges to those
properties again to encourage them back
into use but from next year we are able
to Levy a charge against those
properties and we can introduce a
council tax premium charge on those very
similar to empty homes with the same
purpose to encourage those to be brought
back into use
so in 3.6 you will see what is being
proposed if members were minded to
implement those maximum new charges so
you shall see from there that would mean
that for the current Financial year
things would stay the same
but for the financial year 24 25 those
are the new charges
so the first year Frontline occupied
property there would be no change but
from one year onwards a property remains
empty you would then charge that 100
percent
um and from there after the charges
would remain the same and for second
homes the new charge would be 100 from
24 2024 and the legislation requires
that we agree this in a in the financial
year ahead so if members remind you to
include these charges they wouldn't
apply this year they would apply with
effect from next year
thank you members okay Council stop did
that answer your question that was my
question why are we waiting because of
the legislation we can't do it
penalizing for not being not selling a
property within 12 months so it could be
a little bit difficult
um but I would prefer to see it then
escalating thereafter
um whether it's
um 150 and then 200 or whatever
um to escalate in the subsequent years
um and as far as the
the attacks are premium on um second
homes
um first first of all as question of
information uh do we
um is it are there do we think there are
many in the district to make it
worthwhile doing and can we actually be
sure how we'd identify them
um and to point out further that a lot
of councils are now considering
um uh two or three hundred percent
increases for
um second homes
uh thank you Council suite number I
think if I'm reading this correctly
we've got the um increases
um the new charges for 23 24 which is up
to 300 if I've read that correctly is
that right Mrs Greene that's correct
chairman yeah okay and I've got Council
Lagoon and then councilor Fleming
thank you I just just say that the
report itself is very concise and very
clear and very informative and I'll be
more than happy to to support the report
with the percentile increases or charges
that are levied there because to me it
makes sense okay councilor Fleming
thank you chair
um question for Mr Square New identify
there are 242 second homes
um so if you've identified them you
presumably know which council tax Band
they're in
um roughly do you know what what are the
sort of Finance how will it help our
finances in terms of income generated
just a ballpark figure I was interested
in
um thank you members um the answer is in
it at 3.9.3 so that would generate
potentially uh 476 000 but because the
district council only retainer
proportion of that the net Prof net
income for us would be 51 000.
uh but thank you Mrs Green actually I've
I've got a couple of questions
um the first one is
um what would happen if it was an empty
home and it was lit for a period of say
six months would that then take the
council tax back down to zero or would
it somehow carry on if it had a six
month because I mean they could do a a
short term six-month policy so how does
that affect
um the extra charges um over the years
does it go back to zero
um and the other things were the new
homes bonus I see under
3.8.3 you're actually raising about the
holiday accommodation and say Airbnb or
whatever
um has that been factored in because
that can be quite a good tourist income
because I know that in Edinburgh it's
all about the fits
um which is the free independent
Travelers and obviously we don't want to
lose those so will there be a bit of
work
um to differentiate between those who
might be using them for occasional
income and those who might I mean I know
all the new laws coming in with airbnbs
it all gets a bit more complicated when
it's a um a full house rather than a
single room so there's about 10
questions there I think this is green
sorry
for any period of time where a second
home is occupied as someone's main
residence then that charge won't be
applicable okay
um and then it will effectively the
clock will start from the point where
the property becomes empty or a second
home again okay no problem thank you
that was just a piece of curious when I
was reading it okay at Candace thank you
chairman I
um
my screen won't be able to do it to me
this time because I've actually read
your report properly so uh yeah I was I
was just first of all well done for
reducing the 117 down to 82. you know I
mean it's heartbreaking to see
properties that aren't being used and I
know there's two in southminster one of
them's been empty since um probably
about 50 years so goodness knows what
they're paying and I was quite surprised
that there's 242 second homes that
you've identified in as well so
obviously the revs and Ben's Department
are doing quite a good job sort of
identifying these which I think which is
which I think is very good I mean look I
think at the end of the day you know we
we you know it's our duty to try and get
these homes back into General use and I
think we should we should always apply
the maximum that the government would
allow us in asking for premiums on these
properties so chairman I propose that we
we agree these recommendations and and
thank Miss White for all of her hard
work on this okay all in favor oh cancel
yes okay
thing please
um and Council fluke has triggered
something in my brain so I do apologize
it's totally right the thing is when
you've got um vacated or empty heart
empty homes if you're in a Terry sorry
sent me it causes great deal of stress
for your adjoining neighbor when you've
got rats and mice crawling through and
overgrown so I'd like to congratulate
and I'd say can you please get the 82
down to 10.
thank you thank you councilor Durham
yeah can I just ask Mr Green um will it
be an appeals process I'm thinking of
you know we there's particular house in
my uh Ward that has been the subject of
a probate disagreement for about the
last five years so it's not actually
through any um anybody's fault but will
there be an appeal procedure
it's German there's an internal
procedure where we would undertake an
internal review and if the resident
remains unhappy then there is an appeal
to an appeals tribunal which is
completely independent okay thank you
awesome okay Russ that's all in favor of
that all great perfect okay so we are
thank you Mrs Green
um
oh you've got another one later on um
right okay we've got um number 12 which
is the pay policy statement on pages 233
to 242 which is Mr Leslie
yeah thank you
um it is a statutory requirement that
the council produces a pay policy
statement each year which must cover
Pacific areas it has been updated to
reflect the current position and a key
measure is the pay multiple this is the
ratio between the director salary here
and the medium of all staff which is
3.421 the government considers setting
20 to 1 as a maximum
members we're happy to agree this up
collectively just just a couple of
questions and they're in the pay policy
statement but
um
I I sort of saw this report again in a
different directions but under 2.2.3
that's where the directs have the
delegated powers toward discretionary
points within spinal columns but not
outside of those spinal columns so
um the movement between spinal columns
so if if a member staff moves outside of
their spinal column to another one who
authorizes that and where is it reported
and under 2.5.1 I thought we had a
statutory obligation to provide a
pension and that our staff had to join
the pension scheme but that's it says
they're all legible to join but I
thought it was actually compulsory but I
mean I mean I think the spinal points
one's important bearing in mind what
we're thinking what we're going to be
discussing later thank you
thank you uh Mr Leslie
um thank you so if they're moving
um outside of that um era then it will
have to go through the usual
um process of a new a new post so if
it's not part of the current role then
that's not the ploy won't be on that
scale so we can move them within their
pay bands but if they're not if that
role isn't in the existing Pay Band then
it can't be awarded so I have to go
through um essentially it would have to
be a new role or reassessed through the
HR process has actually having been
carrying out at that level and therefore
entitled
um to that role so there isn't really
scope and to do that just on an icon
basis
just come back on that so so if you went
from a junior role to a senior role and
your spinal column changed because of
that so you'd move up into the next
banding that would be dealt with by HR
and I presume the header paid service
and the other directors and you didn't
answer the question about pensions
yeah yeah thank you so obviously if the
person then literally mean ruse to a new
Pay Band then that's the paper and
they're on and then it can be done
before that but it's not a case if you
can just go oh I'll move you up another
Pay Band because I feel like it has to
have a process behind it um absolutely
and in terms of the pension uh yes
there's a requirement to uh obviously
provide a pension and I think it's all
important actually
um all staff I think specifically it's
the local government pension scheme
that's referring to all staff eligible
for that that pension scheme rather than
perhaps a private scheme so it's
highlighting that and that's obviously
uh one Pacific for the local government
I I got two more who put
them and then cancel
us thank you to just um on page number
241.
um of grades A and B on the right hand
of the column in the top C9 it talks
about the real living wage at set amount
and there's some
money's there some hourly pays which are
less
am I reading I really writing it's
probably covered in the report somewhere
and I've probably missed it but
from from A1 to A2 going up that's under
that
are we obligated to pay that real living
wage
yep so that's been highlighted just to
say that those bands are now under the
um the real living wage and therefore
effectively
um aren't used but I might just refer to
uh Miss cardi just to just to confirm
that that's why they're still shown
because they do exist but they can't but
they're not used because they're under
but um Miss cardio will just to confirm
that is indeed the case
and yes that is correct there is
um able to see
um that
um around in the living wage
um
so it's
um it might be that we need to just
change that part
um because of the rise in the minimum
wage that was just
um gone on to part C and and for DNA and
or above that anyway
um but yes we top them up with a living
wage but we use ours
Pace down to pay the
um according to that but because it's
been over living wage we top it up with
the living wage so effectively that's
always
so just a supplementary so just so I'm
clear on that so the what's the lowest
band that a member of Malden District
Council staff is paid at please
sorry the lowest band on on the grades
what's the lowest band that we actually
use to pay paid people
the name expand his eye apprentices are
played
um on The Apprentice right and depending
on what apprenticeship there are they
may be lower than that but that's the
national government right
no sorry what what do we pay forget
apprentices ftes or equivalents where do
we kick in on paying staff at modern
District Council so this is it C9 or C10
C11 C12 I think I I think if I might
come in I think what councilor login is
asking is can we be certain that all of
the staff that are full-time employees
that are not
um apprentices are on the minimum wage
I'm sure they are because it would be
illegal not to be
so it's only the
and the apprentices that are under the
minimum wage they're on the legal wage
for their pay grade or apprenticeship or
whatever it is
yeah I'll get that thanks for the
intervention okay love you thank you
very much okay right um I've got cancer
the Swain next oh yes thank you Michelle
um I think median maybe what they what
we have to use a median earnings
um but I think it's a bit misleading and
um uh I would certainly like to relate
the top to the bottom bottom of
full-time
um uh a staff or at least an average
figure but the median I think is is
always a bit misleading
okay thank you
um counselor Fleming and then councilor
fluka
thank you chair I'm just turning to page
two four zero
um the 8.2 and 8.3 about the subsistence
allowances I'm going to sound really
really scroogey here
um could Mr Leslie provide the committee
with
um after this evening uh and up year to
date on um how much subsistence
allowance has been claimed um because
just reading that I was a little bit
surprised at in 8.3 where it where
employees can claim expenditure on meals
again without wanting to sound as though
I'm
screwed yeah
um you know this
people can plan ahead they can make a
sandwich and take it with them I sound
Dreadful now but I'm just you know
some days I don't even eat I don't have
time to eat so I don't want to sound
really miserable
thank you okay yeah Mr Liz is going to
take that on um and we'll practice after
this meeting okay right counselor fluka
foreign
with some clever HR people the other day
and you know how much I like HR but they
were talking about you know progression
is almost you know progression comes in
line with recruitment uh and retention
after comes comes after progression
looking at these figures on page 241 if
I if I've understood what Miss Carvey um
just said it apprentices aside
um it appears that from band A1 to C9
because those are paid below the living
wage we pay them all the living wage
because that's what council agreed
nobody earned less than the living wage
so if you were if you were on scale A1
or two there's not really a lot of scent
a lot of incentive to to do the work of
somebody in in C9 because you're not
going to get a financial incentive to do
it now I know that people might look at
that slightly differently but others
will look at it like that so I I do
Wonder
I do Wonder
um if you know maybe we you know we
would change retention and progression
is really really important and I do
wonder if you know we should take the
living wage and then whether or not we
should pay some kind of
slight difference above that on these
walls otherwise everybody's doing
everybody's earning the same amount of
money and it to me
um there has to be responsibilities
built into those spinal columns I'll say
so one would expect that you know there
should be a difference in pay if that
makes sense I mean it's probably just
one of these strange things because we
agreed to pay the the living wage but I
don't know if Miss Carvey wants to have
a look at that and come back or whether
or not we think that's the Prudence that
should apply but I I just feel so you
know some people
might just feel a bit left out if
they're taking on more responsibilities
and and perhaps seek employment
elsewhere
uh Miss cardi
um
appreciate the point but
um we are committed as a council to pay
the living wage
um so in fact we as because of that
commitment we are topping them up to the
real living wage and and obviously
that's to reflect
um the real cost of living and although
it's not
um obviously reflecting the inflation at
the moment
um there is a proposal for next year
through the LGA that we
um as the collectively nationally the
top the lower two brands are deleted
because
um they've recognize the issue between
the very lowest paid and how that's
really not available for subsistence
um so that was
um eradicate this issue so that may be
something I'm I don't think we can at
the moment change those grades because
it does reflect the difference as you've
likely say in the in the post but but
it's our commitment to pay the real
living wage that supersedes that and
there's nothing we could do unless we
change our decision not to or to to
order differently to the real living
wage yeah and that's what probably goes
to the other members I will say I've
raised this with I think I've written Mr
Leslie Miss Dustin but I also fully have
raise it with Mr Mr Johnson today I've
found one of the matter and I know that
someone else members want to do a piece
of work on
um officer training and obviously
progression and moving up pay scales and
upskilling and and getting rewarded for
upskilling so as part of retention of
staff and because obviously important
that we can have mobility and move staff
whether it needs to be moved and reward
them if they do take on extra training
and responsibilities that's something
that I think is really important that
when we have good staff we try and
maintain them or keep them because it's
cheaper to to keep good staff and reward
them than it is to go out and recruit
and I think it's something that Malden
District Council because you've been so
focused on the budget I actually think
we've missed some of these things that
are vitally important and it's all
helped staff morale and staff retention
so again it's something that I've
mentioned that is a piece of what we
want to do but obviously it takes a
little bit of time and to get all these
things done it's only speaking to
officers that you start to realize where
some of these problems are so right okay
I've got cancer Durham then I've got
counselor stamp
yeah chairman I think you know I don't
think it's good to be having a publicly
available pay scale chart
that actually shows an hourly rate below
not only the national living wage but
also the the the the
um the legal national uh the legal wage
which is not currently nine pound fifty
and as we know it's going up to 10 pound
42. so it's rather it's rather
disingenuous that we're actually
printing anything that is below the
legal level that we that we should be
paying
okay thank you Council stamp do we have
a percentage figure of the number of
staff that are paid between a and C
Miss cardi
sorry could you repeat that yes do we
have do you you can do it German you do
we have a um breakdown of the amount of
staff that Ron pay grades a to c that
are full time or the percentage of full
time as opposed to apprentices
okay thank you uh right other than that
is everybody okay to agree this yep okay
excellent right okay moving on
it's quite clear that councilor Dan's
quite tired and and and and it is half
past nine and he's yawning chairman can
I propose that we don't take any new
business after 10 o'clock I've got to be
it that's something and we've actually
got some dates in mind
um I've already been a German no if it
goes past 10 o'clock I will adjourn that
is my decision to adjourn dates that
have been offered are
um either went to the first of February
or Thursday the 9th of February both
were at 7 30 p.m start so it's either of
those two dates that's it that that's
all we can fit in but let's not discuss
that now let's go on let's go on for
next agenda items
um and then we will
um bring bring those forwards
um right okay
um so we are on to agenda item uh 13
which is the more than citizen advice
funding request on pages 200 and 143 to
244 and this is a recommendation to go
to full Council so we're already given a
recommendation or a steer 4 full Council
and that is Mrs Green
thank you members so I'll just give a
brief introduction before introduce to
Mr Wakeling who's
um the chairman of the Board of Trustees
of citizens advice who would like to
make a presentation to members this
evening so the background to the report
is modern citizens advice have been
delivering a a very successful service
for our residents for some years and
under the most current agreement which
was signed in October 2021 they
delivered that service for a fixed price
of 75 000 pounds per year
there's no inflation built into the
contract and there's no specific
provision for an increase in that during
the course of the contract
there is provision however for citizen
advice to make a representation to us on
an annual basis for an increase where
we're satisfied with the performance of
the service
we we have a a twice yearly meeting the
citizens advice Bureau and we do receive
their reports and we are very happy with
the service that is being delivered and
have no issues
um through this and through this process
um citizens advice have flagged up that
they are
suffering from significant pressures
through to the increase in the workload
and the numbers of people that are
contacting them and particularly around
the areas of debt and particularly
around the areas of fuel poverty
therefore they are making a request this
evening for members to consider an
increase in their funding
however since writing this report we've
had some fantastic news and that they
have secured some additional funding and
therefore you're here tonight they
aren't going to be requesting the 14 and
a half thousand and they are only asking
members to consider the inflationary
increase because they have been very
successful in securing some extra
funding
so with that members I'd like to hand
over to Mr White clean yeah thank you
very much
uh Madam chair members thanks very much
for the opportunity to present to you uh
this evening I want to briefly set out
what's changed in our service provision
as a consequence of the cost of living
crisis and as screen as indicated to set
our funding request for the next
financial year
um just bought a background last year we
helped just shy of 3 200 clients working
on something like eleven and a half
thousand issues for them and it's
resulted in an income gain across the
District of some 1.9 million pounds most
of which would anticipate would have
been spent across the district biggest
issues with Benefits housing advice and
debt the most common debt being council
tax careers we'd like to think of the
work that we've done there has helped to
maintain your collection levels and we
provide as you I'm sure no detailed
summaries of activities uh to each Ward
member which should give you a very
clear idea of what's going on precisely
on your particular patch
so what's changed with the cost of
living crisis uh first of all in terms
of charitable support including food
banks demand for our services up by some
250 percent over the course of the year
in the first three weeks of this year
alone we've seen 85 clients for
charitable support and food banks and
this Compares with 34 last year
um turning to debt since the beginning
of October 110 people have had advice
from us about council tax careers that's
an increase of 64
um over the year and in terms of housing
advice with advised 254 clients since
the beginning since the beginning of
October and that's a 25 increase on the
same period last year
so the cost of living crisis is clearly
biting
um in this particular district and it's
underlying a growing need for our
specialist advice services
our response um is that as you know
we're largely volunteer based and we're
attracting new volunteers where we can
and we started training five new
volunteers uh this January we've
increased the hours above staff and
other volunteers to help meet the need
and we've increased our capacity of
training as well but we need yet more
people to join our ranks
our performance though through this
period of stretch has remained uh very
effective 94 of our clients would
recommend our service as a 90 of our
clients found a way forward as a result
of contacting us and dealing with us as
recently as a week or so ago we received
43 out of 45 on a management audit and
that's really important because it
should give confidence to funders such
as yourselves that if you give us money
invest money with us that money is going
to be well spent by robust
well-organized organization
moving on to funding you now provides
rather less than 30 percent of our total
funding and that underwrites most of our
generalist advice the other 70 plus
relates mainly to specialist Services EG
debt and housing advice and that's
secured on a variety of contracts which
expire on a one to five year period now
a number of those contracts are expiring
and six months ago we flagged uh to the
district council that we would then
expect to have a potential deficit of a
new order of 70 000 pounds we worked
hard to secure additional lines of
funding and we reduce that funding Gap
to some fourteen thousand pounds as
reported by Mrs greenle reported that to
the liaison group back in December but
the good news is as you've just heard
due to new Arrangements we've secured
with Essex citizens advice with national
citizens advice and with Essex County
Council plus some other third-party
funders
um we've now sentient really got the
money that we need to provide the
additional Services over and above
generalist advice so therefore don't
need to come to you for the extra
fourteen thousand pounds we're
contemplating doing earlier on however
our request is therefore only in
relation to our contract with yourselves
the contract provides for an annual
review of our charge and we propose that
it should increase by a sub-inflationary
six percent it's about four and a half
thousand pounds to reflect just some of
the effects of inflation which we're
having to deal with in delivering our
services this will enable us to balance
our budget and that's really important
from our point of view because we've got
to look at the long-term viability and
sustainability of our services so we
would request a six percent increase in
our base fee for core services in the
next financial year thank you
thank you um just to clarify Mrs Green
it is just for the next financial year
it's not going forwards no this is only
for the next financial year yeah okay
uh members okay uh councilor stamp
thank you thank you for the presentation
um can I actually ask Mr Wakeland how
much did you get
um that's covered the 14 000 so did you
get fourteen thousand fifteen thousand
sixteen thousand and also I'm pleased
you've clarified that they only have
requested it for one year because I can
remember when this came to cancer I
think we did it on Zoom I think it was
all on zoom and we when we discussed
this funding and this fixed three-year
contract
um and I know it's hard to actually see
envisage that inflation was going to go
so high
um I think you ask correct me if I'm
wrong but I think you actually asked for
more money than what's originally going
to be granted the last time round please
refresh my memory members I I didn't can
you can anybody remember all I want to
know is I know you do an excellent
service but I think our residents if
we're going to give more money away
we've we've been talking about how
struck we are for cash and I know you
provide a fantastic service but we need
to be scrutinized if we you know if
we've got that money to give so please
don't take offense at my questions thank
you everyone I can't be precise about 14
sorry I can't be precise about the 14
000 pounds but we have secured about 14
000 pounds to fill that Gap and indeed
we've secured round about 70 000 pounds
between now and last June uh to fill
that particular Gap so we're working on
our budget at the moment so just like
you we're putting the numbers together
and our budget will be confirmed at our
February board meeting so what I'm
giving you at the moment are indicative
figures but we have got sufficient money
to we think a couple of those specialist
Services as to the proposal we made I
can't remember now a year 18 months ago
um as Mrs greens indicated we entered
into a new three-year term with you at
the 75
000 pound limit then
and
I'm talking about yeah so based on that
and you're going to do your budgets in
February would it not be prudent that
you then came back to us if there was a
shortfall to ask us for that six percent
so it could because it could be five
percent it could be four percent you
know it could be less money that we're
paying out if you're you can cover your
own costs that's all I'm saying thank
you madam chair
that's what's going to see but I'm
talking about four and a half thousand
pounds it's probably the Minimus we
might be a few hundred pounds above a
few hundred pounds below if you wish me
to come back I'd be delighted to come
back in February to confirm precisely
where we are the other members may not
just thinking so it's fine okay thank
you
okay
um councilor I've got councilor lag and
then councilor siddle Council Channel
councilor Durham so Council lagam and
yeah I'll be did be very quickly
um the service you provide is absolutely
fantastic and I seem to remember that
the savings to this Council um that were
promoted when we made the award of the
support
um were weren't significant they were
enormous so I I'm more than happy to to
support you know this because we'd have
to amend the recommendation when it
comes to that recommendation one and two
um but absolutely 100 behind what you do
and support here with that small sum of
money thank you very great if you to
come forward and actually be open and
honest not say we want the whole lot
okay
um when I've got um councilor siddle
next
thank you chair uh yeah I'm gonna back
up what council wagons just said that
yeah the the amount of money that we
give as a grant and what that then saves
us as a council yeah it pays back in
bucket loans basically
um and in in terms of the four and a
half thousand I think that's a a
reasonable amount I presume that will be
an additional four and a half thousand
over the next few years yeah so so that
is so not just this year but four and a
half thousand for each of the following
years yes that's correct no no no no
just just for this year oh that's why I
don't want to clarify is it just for
this year
four and a half thousand
well that's so therefore it will be next
year
CFE or 79 500 each year from this moment
onwards that's my anticipation yes yeah
because inflation's not going to go down
the numbers have gone up and we are
paying those bills yeah oh hang on
yeah hang on councilman for clarity I
didn't think we were setting a service
level agreement going forwards because
that will affect the SLA which we gave
an extended period to
um so I don't know if we can actually
decide this anyway if you want to alter
the entire SLA I thought this was only a
an additional inflationary budget for
this one year because I think in that's
the fact that we need to can this and
come back with a brand new SLA we can't
we can't alter the SLA I didn't think we
could also the SLA
um chairman if I can clarify the
arrangement we have in place is it has
gone through a full procurement so it is
a contract and it is a fixed price
contract 75 000 per year with the
provision that in any year the citizens
advice can back to can come back to make
a request for further funding yes but
it's in relation to that Financial year
so any future years it would go back to
75 000 and then they would need to
exactly because I was just all of a
sudden I was like Hannah this is every
year I'm like hell we can't do that
because the service level agreement that
we have I'm like uh hang on a minute I
know it's late but I'm not that that
asleep
um yeah I mean okay right so that's also
it's definitely only for this year but
it's not going to affect the service
level agreement that we have going
forwards no and there is no inflationary
increase built into the contract it is
just a set perfect right okay so they're
just asking for a gift of this year a
separate a separate gift a traditional
right okay um counselor siddle yeah uh I
I want that's yeah I wanted to make sure
that was direct however I would be happy
to pay another four and a half thousand
profits just from my own personal point
of view I think that amount is smaller
than I think you know hopefully if there
is a need that you will come back next
year
um and we can look at that again I would
prefer it that if we just said it's four
and a half hour but it wouldn't yeah
that's what we can't do at this
particularly I don't think we can offer
additional funding now yeah I know we've
clarified that so I'm just saying yeah
that's my personal view yeah but we need
we need to be careful that we are in in
Open Session and this is public we're
asking them to apply for more money my
personal opinion is that is that should
be ongoing is a personal opinion because
the service that you provide is
invaluable to our residents and in the
long term it saves this Council a huge
amount of money
um so therefore yeah I fully support
what we're doing and I would support any
increase in the future
um counselor Channel
thank you I can appreciate the
sentiments that councilor sigils just
expressed actually
um and what I would um would say is um
this has been clarified it is for one
year an uplift uh actual inflation six
percent and I'm happy to move that
proposal um Madam chairman I'm not going
to reiterate everything councilman
signal said I can remember how the
citizens advice Bureau actually assisted
this Council greatly
um through covert dialing things and our
Housing Services I'm very well aware
that without the assistance of the a
Citizens advice Bureau where this
Council might otherwise have been so I'm
happy to propose little to Chairman that
we do give that inflationary increase of
six percent and for the reasons Council
again and councilor siddle have said
thank you yeah okay and uh just before
we take the vote I've got three more
people wanting to speak I've got cancer
Durham
councilor Fluker and then councilman if
you just want to Second counselor
China's
um
motion on the resolution and I'm I'm
your proposal I'm happy with that yeah I
was second in cancer Chan has proposal
yeah two and also to uh agree completely
with everything she's just said yeah
okay um but but we need to be careful
because we mustn't affect the SLA um
right councilor Durham and then
counselor fluka yeah thank you thank you
chairman
chairman as you well know I mean the
funding for the the citizens advice
Bureau has been a hot topic for about 12
years I mean every time it comes up
there is a very heated debate and I
recall uh quite a lot of meetings where
we put the previous chairman David
Pickles I think it was through the
ringer
um and you know we we were very we were
very firm uh and we did say to them you
need to not rely solely on Morgan
District Council for your funding you
need to go out and look for external
funding and I'm really pleased to hear
that they've been successful and done
that and I hope they continue to do so
and of course we also have to bear in
mind that they they benefit from a
pepcon rent from their premises which
not all cabs do yeah and I think the
other really important point to notice
is that when this SLA and when the
procurement took place and when the SLA
started
we were in a very different place
and now actually our residents need the
cab services more than ever
um because the sorts of problems that
residents are experiencing now we'd
never dreamed we're going to be as
prevalent um when we did the procurement
so again I do support the additional
four and a half thousand pounds um and
as I said I'd like to congratulate the
cab board for attracting the other the
other grant funding thank you okay and
um I think there's cancer fluka next
sorry
thank you chairman you know I'm you know
Mr Wakeling has had to
um
the sufferance of listening to the
budget discussion tonight so he'll he'll
know exactly where the council is
um I mean I think when this report goes
to to uh to four counts so I think it
would be very useful if if it would be
possible to have a like for night
comparison with Chelmsford because I
have my own research shows that
Chelmsford is a lot busier than Malden
by virtue of the size of the local
Authority area that it's dealing with
and also it deals with far more people
outside of the district and I I I don't
know I know that Malden used to be
adverse to that and I don't know whether
or not they support people outside the
district and the reason why I think that
would be important to see because they
um Chumps had only received 99
000 pounds from um Chelmsford Borough
Council and I so City oh city is it a
city
um and of course the overarching thing
is is whether or not you know bear in
mind the two cabs do so much similar
work across a quite a large area you
know we've spoken in the past about
merging uh whether or not the two should
be merged and whether or not that would
present better value
um and I think what councilor Durham
says is quite right but I can remember
years ago when these discussions weren't
so protracted because we members were
directly involved with the cab and I
think at one time and I joined the
council some members were actually
trustees or something of the and and
it's that seemed to work much better
um so that we fully understood I don't
think anybody doesn't understand what
the Cav does and it doesn't understand
you know and it sees the value it
provides for this Council but I think we
need to sort of look at you know some of
the things that Mr Wakeling said I mean
he spoke to inflation
now most businesses are suffering
inflation around their rents their costs
for electricity and and other services
well obviously that's all provided for
your charge so
still thinking about inflation I'm
wondering where this this inflation
figure comes into which this four and a
half thousand pounds needs to
um satisfy so I think before I say
anything else I should commend the
fiscal position of the cab I think it's
interesting that
um your net cash assets Rose from 147
000 to 155 000 that was up to March this
year
um they're the figures that are at
companies house and I think that's you
know worth bearing in mind that your
cash Rich based on what you're actually
providing but the most extraordinary
thing that I've found and bear in mind
you know I've been listening to these
well-rehearsed arguments with the cab
for quite a number of years now was the
fact that your establishment has now
risen
um to 14 part-time staff and seven fixed
term employees who are full-time
employees a big problem and again this
is the information that's readily
available from companies house but the
sum total of paying no staff is 237
000 pounds with one member of Staff
getting sixty thousand pounds so you
know
this inflation is it is it to do with
you know are you increasing your you
know are you paying your plan to pay
your staff more and this is what this
inflationary
um sum is going to be used for
um you know and I'm not expecting you to
ask all of these questions now but I
think these are the questions that need
to be asked when this goes to full
Council because I think there will be a
lot of due diligence around this you
know we've got
we've got a device Bureau with quite
large cassette assets there's large cash
assets there's a large payroll uh and on
paper as a business it all looks quite
good
um so I hope that when you come to
council you're you'll be able to have
some answers to those questions and and
if I can through you to miss green it
would be interesting to see what
um Chumps that are actually providing
and in relation to the 99
000 they get from the city council thank
you
uh yeah I think but I think I think
rather than
um prolong it too long tonight is it's
kicking on 10 o'clock
um it might be interesting full Council
just to have a breakdown of the accounts
between
um Malden and Thompson so just for
comparison and on the accounts does it
take into account the peppercorn rent I
can't remember how that's worked out I
haven't seen the
I can't remember I can't remember the
last time we we did the um budget
increase
um but I think I'm happy for that to go
forwards but then to to council but it
would be interesting to get the
information that Council fluke has
requested um councilor Channel thank you
well alongside that then Madam chairman
I think what I'd also like from this
Authority going to that meeting would be
the impacts and risks if we don't have a
cab or perhaps don't give this and what
it does what does it and what it equates
for this Authority sorry Council fluka I
didn't quite hear I mean there's
absolutely no good question you've asked
me through the through the chair
um
I am speaking about due diligence and
best value for this Council and and and
and I know that there is a world
rehearsed argument why we need this but
what we're actually discussing here is
an inflationary increase and all I've
done is bring to the the committee's
attention the intelligence in the
background which I'm sure that Mr
Wakeling will be able to embellish when
he goes to council to actually further
and enhance his argument for this four
and a half thousand pounds
yeah I mean if I might if my mates from
the chair nobody wants to do away with
the cab least of all the chairman and
their other members nobody wants to away
with but I think
um Council figure someone's Clarity
going forward to the the next
um to civil Council so Council uh so Mr
wait waitling because I should know
um it's tired tired it's only 10 o'clock
and Mr Wakeling can put for these other
arguments it's just further information
I I think nobody needs to be aware that
anybody here wants to own the cab that's
absolutely certain
um so uh please be assured with that one
um right counselor Channel well I just
spoke my point again let's hear while
we're having this argument we've all
recognized they're good value for money
I'm saying there's an impact here as
well and that's what I'm just asking we
need to have a balanced view
um Council of uh fluke has given us
loads of information which is courses on
companies house I can do we can do that
for every company I think that's
excessive information with all due
respect and miss and I'm sure Mr
Wakeling will produce quite clearly the
further information that might be
helpful at full Council yeah but I would
also like Mike my point made and the
impacts and risks
Etc thank you madam chairman we know as
a counselor
um Durham indicated this life has
changed we're in a different world now
we've had the covid pandemic and we're
now cost of living and you know we've
got to recognize various things thank
you absolutely and no nobody's disputing
that but I think we just want to make
sure that we're actually spending the
taxpayers money wisely and if if a
company has got an awful lot of cash
assets you know where are we but we
don't want to do all this area right
okay just quickly I've got Council
stamps thank you for allowing me to come
back because I think it's really
important that it wasn't taken out of
context and I also thank you for
actually saying because I raised some
queries right at the very beginning and
there's no way I would want to get rid
of it because there's one in Burnham on
Crash and we know how many people
so actually thank you for doing that and
please don't take it out context we're
here to scrutinize whether we all agree
or we disagree it shouldn't be personal
like that I'm sorry chairman absolutely
and that's why I raised it is it was
starting to sound like we always do away
with the saving I'm like well speaking
as a champion we absolutely do not want
to deal with it um okay Council Fleming
thank you everything's always about
money isn't it and so the bottom line is
that it would cost us a lot more than 75
000 pounds a year plus the four and a
half to deliver that service and that's
the bottom line and that's what you've
got to look at it's value for money for
us thank you but this this will be
determined at full Council and I think
we've requested the other information
that councilor fluka requires
um right okay members are we all happy
with that going forward to council yes
agrees right perfect now tell me can we
do the
um data management and insight strategy
in five minutes
situations
is it just a report at the very least I
think 1918
okay yeah okay right okay yep member's
right okay now we aren't a journey
meeting but before we adjourn it
um item 18 uh which is on pages 391 to
394 which is supplementary estimates
environments procurement exemptions and
use of reserves first of October no this
is just a noting report this is this is
only for noting
yeah okay members do you want to note
the report now or do you want it to be
noted at the next meeting a show of
hands please all those in favor and
those not in favor
[Music]
that officers have acted incorrectly and
I want to bring that to the attention of
the meeting that can wait chairman until
uh next meeting
okay leave that we won't do anything
tonight we're all tired Madam chairman
now that's now that's been said actually
I I don't know that we want um that to
linger for another period of time quite
frankly because having had that
statement made we need that clarified
within this chamber chairman that the
satisfaction of what I just said rests
in 3.4.1 of the report there was one
supplement mentioned we're being asked
to to agree a supplementary estimate
which the officers have already as far
the way I've read this the business has
been done and we are only being asked to
notice it noted what I'm saying is I
believe that there's been a default and
that the council has acted incorrectly
could Mr Leslie come back to you on that
one
yeah yeah and 3.1.1
um there's a supplementary estimates up
to 20 000 director of resources and
consultation consultation with the
chairman of the strategy and resource
committee and lead of the council and it
has to be reported to the next uh SNR
committee so the consultation
um happened the money was approved under
that which is consistent with the
financial regulations per the
Constitution and per their it now being
reported to SNR so it's just for SNR to
note it well chairman something here
doesn't add up because Mr Leslie has
insisted that this report comes to this
meeting tonight for us to note
effectively
but there's absolutely no reason not to
note it at the next meeting so why the
urgency to note it tonight as I said I
believe that there's been a breach of
the procurement rules in relation to
this uh procurement and there's two ways
of doing this in strategy and resources
next time or through a motions Council
yeah I think do it next time it's too
late to do it now I certainly don't want
to do it now
um I I think we'll bring it back and
we'll make sure we've got a robust
report
um for the next meeting now members
would I need a show of hands would you
prefer the meeting on the 1st of
November or the 9th of November and
sorry sorry February I'm looking at
another report uh the first or the ninth
um German can I chairman can I propose
it if we are going to enjoy it turn
whether the question should be put to
members and officers is whether or not
bearing in mind it took us three hours
to complete this meeting last time and
three hours in complete Council on a
German can I propose that we start at
half past at start at seven rather than
half past seven
um
but I'm going to bring forth emotion on
that yeah sure it's only it's only going
to have six items we've managed to get
I think for this challenge going
forwards we can perhaps look at my my
intelligence suggests that one of those
items may take up an hour and a half
easily I've just been told
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay right the directors are fine with
the earlier start time of 7 P.M but
members I think for clarity for officers
we need to decide tonight which meeting
we're going to go for so no every not
everybody's gonna be able to attend both
meetings so we're going to have to do on
a show of hands and whatever the
majority can attend we'll go with that
one so can I have a show of hands for
the first what day is the first
Wednesday so it's either Wednesday
Wednesday the first so so how many
members are happy with the first of
February
four okay that's four and how many are
happy for the ninth of February okay
it's the 9th of February then so I'm
going to it is
um ten minutes past three so
oh God three minutes past ten I'm tired
past my bedtime I'm close to me three
minutes past ten I'm gonna go to adjourn
the meeting and we'll reconvene on the
9th of February at 7 00 P.M